[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
assalamualaikum greetings of peace I'm
very excited we got a new and exciting
episode every weekend hamdulillah this
week is no exception
why everyone she wanted listen neighbor
you'd be the happiest honestly if a
Muslim family moved next door to you you
would be the happiest person in the
world also my guest touches upon if
Islam is so bad why they want to know
more so if it's so bad if it's so why is
everyone trying to attack if it's re if
it's so bad then you wouldn't have to
right they wouldn't have to spend
millions and hundreds of millions of
dollars to defame our Deen
so all this and more on this week's
exciting episode of the D show listen
subscribe right now because you will be
getting up-to-date shows every week we
put out a new show God one inshallah
every Friday and you'll get it and make
sure you press the little bell right
there now they have you pressing it so
then you can make sure you get it in
your notifications so subscribe get the
show every week sent to you and I'll see
you next time until then Salam alaikum
peace be with you
[Applause]